moment où tout le monde parle de
démondialisation de rapatrier des
productions en france et bien à ce
moment-là elle choisit de nous dire que
elle est heureuse d'avoir passé un
nouvel accord de libre échange c'est à
dire finalement de continuer sur la
lignée où elle est elle qui est de
répartir dans le monde
les productions selon les pays donc
c'est un sens du timing assez
exceptionnelle puisqu'elle fait la
démonstration que pendant la pandémie et
pendant que tout le monde se pose la
question de re re développer des
industries nationales
eh bien elle fait le contraire ce qu'il
y à nouveau dans cet accord c'est que
c'est la disparition de certaines de
certaines contraintes comme ils disent
c'est à dire en fait d'un certain
protectionnisme qui existaient de la
part de la part du mexique qui avaient
des droits de douane sur certains
produits que ses doigts de roanne vont
êtres vont être complètement disparaître
complètement puisqu'ils sont ils sont
nuls à 0